we are live
hello everybody hi
hi
so bear with us we are doing this for
the first time um we're doing it on my
cell phone actually so i will be trying
to periodically
check comments to make sure that we're
not missing anything um
and make sure that you guys are able to
see everything but let's get started and
dive right into this
we are making
cake mix cookies this is a really easy
way to let kids cook by themselves and
do baking by themselves there's very
minimal measuring it's also really great
if you don't have flour which we're
having a really hard time finding flour
right now
but we could secure some cake mix and
there are really infinite possibilities
with this so
should we get started
yeah yes did we wash our hands yeah nice
and clean nice and clean and our oven is
pre-heated to 350 degrees fahrenheit and
we're going to get started
so essentially the formula for
cake mix i can't see me the formula for
cake mix cookies is um
one box of cake mix and then about a
half cup of oil and two eggs but this
isn't one size fits all so we're gonna
show you kind of how you work around the
different variations of cake mix because
they're not all made the same um to make
sure that you don't end up with a
literal pan full of like splooted
splat cookies because trust me it's
happened to me before
so wyatt is going to handle
dry ingredients jackson you're going to
handle cracking the eggs and what we're
going to start out with is one packet of
red velvet cookie mix or red velvet cake
mix sorry right you're going to pour
this in your bowl
and jackson you're going to crack two
eggs
tip for cooking with kids if they're
cracking eggs have them crack them in a
separate bowl instead of over your
batter mixture because then you're not
fishing eggshells out of the
actual like mixture you can just fish
them easier out of an individual bowl
trying to pour this in
so i'll be giving lots of alternatives
too as we go
um for those who don't have eggs
um
you can try a fourth a cup of banana per
egg it's a great substitution for baking
um
oh okay
you know decorate your floor with some
of the cake mix
why
not how you doing
you good
great
so for this cake mix
um because we're going to do a red
velvet with a cream cheese mix in
i'm actually
going to we'll put in the eggs can you
pour those in
and then we're going to add the oil but
instead of adding a half cup of oil
we're going to start with a third cup
because if you're adding a wet
ingredient like cream cheese it might
add a little more moisture
um and we don't want to have too much
oil if we're doing that
so do you want to pour in the oil honey
yes he does dry ingredients well he's
doing a wet one
change of plans
then do you guys want to start stirring
i'm going to bring the camera forward so
you can see this mixture
oh my god and really if you have any any
mix cook along with us
let's bring this a little closer
okay
yep start stirring
and i'll show you the consistency
oh that means my oven's preheated
show you the consistency that it should
feel like
um
hi there
it should be
pretty thick like a cookie batter or a
cookie cookie dough why'd i just call it
a batter
and then jackson if you're having a
little trouble why it can take a turn
too
we're gonna make two different kinds of
cake mix cookies right now
and then
uh we'll give some alternatives for
different flavors after
[Music]
you want to turn
jackson can wyatt have a turn yeah sure
excellent oh my gosh look at them being
so nice to each other
hello in indonesia
in atlanta
how's everybody doing today
oh wyatt's being super careful i love
this
he's folding he's folding look at this
he's folding the mixture
wyatt is bound to be a chef
can i try
do you want me to help you a little bit
okay okay
we're just gonna try to get this
whipped up let me tilt down so y'all can
see
here let me just mix this up and then
you guys can add the cream cheese
so again
the basic formula that you want to start
off with is
um
one box of cake mix
two eggs and then
either a third cup of oil if you're
mixing in
a wet mix in or half a cup of oil if
you're mixing
one cup of dry mix in so you see we have
chocolate chips here we're going to show
you
how to do that next when we're doing a
dry ingredient to mix in
and really for this red velvet if i had
some white chocolate chips i would
totally be all about that because
oh my gosh that would be delicious with
this oh yeah but we love red velvet cake
with cream cheese frosting
so we figured cream cheese would be a
really nice addition to this
oh it's so fluffy what does it smell
like
give it a smell oh it smells like cake
smells like cake chocolate cake
chocolate cake
what does it smell like to you wyatt
chocolate cake
i knew it
almost mixed then who's gonna pour in
the cream cheese it's kind of close to
you wyatt so why don't you dump the
cream cheese in
so i'll bring this a little closer so
everybody can see
why don't you take the spoon and scoop
it all in
just you can hold the bowl up and then
dump it out ready
pull it out
so close
excellent
do we want to use that spin to stir
sure
so this is one half a cup of cream
cheese
and we want to stir it enough but not
too much so the ribbons disappear
we want to get some nice ribbons of
cream cheese
in this mixture
oh look at that do you want to try
jackson
it looks like toothpaste you know like
the toothpaste that has the different
colored lines look at that
well this kind of reminds me of
peppermint
ooh it's pretty huh
it reminds me of
uh
red velvet
it is red velvet
hello anybody have any questions or any
alternative ingredients they're trying
to use
[Music]
i'm going to raise this
i saw some people saying candy melts
candy melts are a great
decoration for these cookies
you can make them and then melt down the
candy melts and do a cute little design
or just frost them
um
and it's really festive for easter we're
making a lot of cookies because we're
doing contactless
drop-offs of cookie deliveries to some
of our family
sure just a little bit more because
we're almost ready
we have a baking
sheet
what's that for
this is for our next batch
excellent it looks really good let me
hold it up to the camera
so people can see our little ribbons of
cream cheese
look at that
so do you see the consistency it's
pretty thick
it separates really easily
so for people just joining this is one
box of cake mix two eggs a third cup of
oil
and a half cup of cream cheese we're
going to spoon this
onto a baking sheet i like to give them
a little extra space in case they spread
out so let me show you guys how to do it
and then you can do it
so it's almost like
i'd say this is about two tablespoons
full
so i just take one scoop with the spoon
and
i lay it out with the other
do you want to try yeah okay
[Music]
you get to try two
one
he'll do one and then you try one give a
little space a little space there we go
beautiful
let's just get that
yep
right you want to try one
hi there
mini marshmallows yes oh my gosh they're
so good in cake mix cookies if you have
graham crackers too
you can mix those in as well in like a
chocolate cake mix
it is delicious yes
it's hard to do do you want to take the
other spoons
yeah what you need let's do it together
and scrape it off so if you're if you
have kids you're looking for something
to do an easter activity
this is okay so i'm gonna hold it you
scoop it
and we'll scoop it together this is a
great easter activity to do together and
it's very simple it's not going to use
up a bunch of extra stuff and you can
use a lot of things that you already
have in your
pantry
so like i said if i had white chocolate
chips i would be all over that right now
and
mixing them in here too probably a half
a cup of white chocolate chips
and i said earlier with substituting for
eggs if you don't have any eggs there
are lots of great baking substitutions i
usually will do
fourth a cup of mashed banana
so these are ready to go in the oven
they're not the prettiest but
they're homemade by children what do you
expect
these are going to be for 10 to 12
minutes i'm going to set my timer
for 11 minutes and check on them i have
my oven rack set to the
goodbye
i have my oven rack set to the middle
and
while those are baking
let's make our chocolate chip ones
so these are just basic chocolate chip
cake mix cookies
you can use whatever flavor you'd like i
would recommend a yellow cake mix
because that is going to make the color
more similar to a chocolate chip cookie
we only have white so these are going to
look a little pale for a chocolate chip
cookie but they taste amazing
so jackson should we do the same thing
again yeah
you crack the eggs you
pour in the cake mix
what do i want
in the bowl
i'm just gonna give this a little rinse
hold in the cake mix
so look what i'm gonna do i'm gonna wet
my fingers
and i'm gonna scoop it out
just like that you saved the day
so let's get closer on what they're
doing
hello i hope everyone's having a good
saturday
ready to pour it in yep okay
let's get closer on the mixture
i'm gonna lower this a little bit
banana or blueberries oh my gosh
delish
you can definitely put banana mashed
banana in these to add a little flavor
and then again we're going to start with
a third cup of oil because
different cake mixes require different
amounts of wet ingredients
so some will require
one cup of water some will require one
and a half or a fourth cups of water so
depending on that
that's going to decide how much oil yeah
so we'll start with the third just in
case this mix in particular doesn't need
as many wet ingredients i have to really
crouch down to see you
okay so should we take turns mixing yeah
mix
clear off the table a little bit
i'll leave you to it you guys know what
to do
i'll look at some of the comments
hi
how are we doing we're doing great we're
so excited for these cookies we really
miss
our extended family we can do our egg
hunt an easter hunt yes we're doing it
inside our home
now could i try
sure
nice job but it's a really nice way to
just tell people we love them by
dropping a little batch of cookies on
their doorstep
rosie is not cooking our dog is rosie
for those who are curious
okay
um she's not allowed
to cook because she licks everything up
off the floor and if our
if the kids dropped a chocolate chip or
something i would
be very sad if she ate it
because rosie's are
only calling this dog she's calm one huh
yeah but poppy's the crazy one she's
wild okay so this consistency actually
with a third cup of oil
this was perfect i'm going to hold it up
so you can see
see that
it looks like
cookie dough
oh and this one smells good you guys
want to smell and tell me what you smell
vanilla vanilla
just kind of like really
yummy batter so we're going to take
a cup of chocolate chips mix those in
these are going to be our chocolate chip
cookies it's raining chocolate chip it's
raining and chocolate
it's snapping
snapping
oh you can hear them rattling around huh
hello
neapolitan cookies ooh that would be so
much fun
[Music]
mayonnaise and cake mix i've heard that
hack
mayonnaise and cake you can't taste it
when it's baked
vanilla extract
sure you can add some vanilla extract
i'm i don't really feel like we need it
so i'm not going to use it if i don't
have to because i don't have that much
left and
i don't know if i'm going to be able to
find it
okay anyone just joining
yeah we're making cake mix cookies this
is one box of white cake mix
a third cup of oil and two eggs and one
cup of chocolate chips
and we are just mixing it thoroughly
getting these chocolate chips dispersed
oh
okay look at this
that's a real cookie why it says
he says it's a real cookie we're
starting simple with these lives i'm
really open to suggestions too of what
you want to see but we're trying to do a
quick recipe so this doesn't drag out
for like two hours
but it's time to scoop
let's get
[Music]
yes
okay
now it's time to skip it's time to scoop
let's get our baking sheet
oh let's just take a peek oh my gosh
our red velvet cookies look so
good
i think you need a little bit more honey
let me get you a big one and you can
dump it oh you got it he's got it
what i'll do the scraping
thank you everyone saying i'm a nice mom
that's very nice
oh wow
oh okay can i help
oh it's small it's small but
it's not broken we can fix it
here
there you go
there you go
oh
excellent
what let's do here can i help you what
are you doing that's too small that's
not a cookie
salted caramel mmm ooh salted caramel so
good
okay let's do these
here let me show you a scoop first then
you know how much to do ready
let me show you one
we're gonna do big guys
big cookie
what happened to my parchment
i'm so excited for tomorrow so these
cookies if you are a person who loves
like thin crispy cookies this probably
isn't for you because it's made with
cake mix they're very like fluffy
soft cookies which is my personal
favorite
careful we don't want to over mix
yep
it's my personal favorite to have like a
big fluffy soft cookie oh my gosh this
one has a billion chocolate chips
i remember making stuffed cookies
yeah
you could stuff these with like a little
peanut butter cup or something okay so
we have this one do you guys want to try
on a second pan yeah we need to make
more cookies
here you go we don't need to mix it
anymore but we can
scoop them can i try doing this for it
oh strawberries and cream i need a
square
you can do one after him
[Music]
so strawberries and cream there's
actually a great recipe on tasty.com for
strawberries and cream cake mix cookies
you need white chocolate you need
chopped strawberries and cream cheese
and it's absolutely delicious
do you want to try to round that out a
little bit more
what's behind your ears oh it's a bird
can you use brownie mix i will test it
with brownie mix and i will let you know
any questions anyone joining
you know after we've already explained
this
how many ingredients chocolate chip i
mean it's as little as
three if you just want to do the cake
mix the eggs and the oil
and you can have as many as you know
five if you wanted to make some walnuts
in with these chocolate chip cookies
that would be incredible
these are more like free-form shapes
we're not gonna call them cookies on
this pan
these are abstract cookies
look at why he's just in his element oh
gosh do it wyatt do it let's see what
happens
this is the time when you're cooking
with kids you really have to be flexible
and pretty playful about it you can't be
a perfectionist so i try to step back i
try not to correct too much
because the most important part is that
they're having fun
that's a big cookie yes
this is how much it is
okay why don't you add it to one of
these little guys
so we are almost finished this is oh
boy okay i'm very excited for these
so actually our red velvets have about
30 seconds
30 seconds these are gonna go in the
oven one
two after them
five
but so that you don't have to wait
another 12 minutes i actually baked a
batch of chocolate chips last night so
you can see what they look like
wow
so when i bring the hot pan out
everybody
the teal is
nobody's listening to it
okay
so everybody stay back
whoa
back back back it's a hot pan
i'm gonna put a little
hot pan just gonna set a bit down here
watch out guys
oh look at these little cookies
stay back it's very very hot
look how big they are they're puffy
they're like pillowy delicious you can
still see the ribbons get your hand away
oh my goodness you can still see the
ribbons of cream cheese
i already chose that one
get your hands
if someone puts their hand near it
they're not gonna be able to eat a
cookie because they're gonna be getting
treated for burns
like yeah
so
um this is what the red velvet turns out
like and we actually made a couple
others just to show you
alternatives so
this is what the chocolate chip looks
like out of the oven
like i said we used
white cake mix so it's going to be a
little pale scoop back jackson you were
uncomfortably close to that pan
back back
don't touch the table that's the rules
okay
so
these are a little pale compared to a
regular cookie dough
because it's a white cake mix if you
want to use yellow it'll look a little
closer so this is what the chocolate
chips look like they're very
thick
pillowy cookies
and then we also made just
if you want to use up a little peanut
butter this is
probably my favorite
version
of my favorite this is chocolate cake
mix
with um
peanut butter mixed in so this was
one package of chocolate cake mix
a third cup of oil two eggs and one cup
of um smooth peanut butter and i just
took a fork and made these little
imprints
and these are absolutely delicious too
so the op the options are really endless
um we are really looking forward to
enjoying these all together let me get
this up
and
hope you had fun with us let me scoot
this over oh my goodness oh my goodness
sorry everybody
my tripod's going wild
yes you can add cookies in crushed
cookies
can you eat raw cookie dough i do not
recommend that
um even with this it has raw eggs and
raw flour in the cake mix
um but we're going to cool these bake
off the rest and
yeah get them all together and enjoy do
you guys want to take a bite
which one do you want to try i want to
try this one
grab it
give it a taste
[Music]
good
you guys did amazing high fives
all right thank you everybody we're
gonna go now
you wanna say bye bye
you